[Music]
we all come here for learning we all
come here for learning here we are very
excited about education
finally back to school
sometimes class is still outdoors like
here in india
in burundi everyone is happy to see
their friends again
lockdown for many like this boy in peru
meant sitting home alone too much screen
time and too much loneliness can make a
child ill
in europe the number of children with
depression has risen sharply in the
pandemic
globally one in four children is said to
be affected
in germany eating disorders among
children increased by almost 10 percent
clearly closing schools had massive
consequences around the world
welcome to our kobe 19 special i'm
monica jones good to have you with us
now it's no secret that the coronavirus
pandemic now in its 20th month
is having an ongoing impact on society
to curb the spread of infections we all
have to deal with many restrictions
adding to our daily grind and kids make
no exception
here's how family in berlin is coping
with it all
breakfast time at the philip family the
last few sandwiches are being made
before all five children head off to
school
just like their mother juliana who's a
teacher herself
after a year and a half of homeschooling
and video conferences everyone here is
happy that schools have finally reopened
properly
it's so important instead of hanging
around at home with all these video
conferences then there was homework but
they didn't feel like it then i had to
motivate them meanwhile i had to take
care of my own students it was just a
real pain and now i can only say finally
i'm very happy schools have reopened
because now i can see my friends much
more often
homeschooling just wasn't fun you didn't
get any real lessons if you had
questions they couldn't be answered
properly
[Music]
families like the phillips have suffered
particularly under the restrictions
during the pandemic
now parents and children hope that
schools will stay open this winter
but schools are still affected by the
pandemic
rooms need to be aired testing happens
regularly
masks are mandatory
especially important at primary schools
because in germany there's still no
approved vaccination for children under
12 years old
the mask is a must but for the young
ones it makes learning how to read and
write very difficult because they can't
see my mouth so when i stand in front of
them with the windows open i sometimes
take the mask down briefly to
demonstrate things
is safe
she has been vaccinated against covet
the same goes for daniel and juliana
philip
they hope that teaching will soon be the
same as it was before the pandemic
a high vaccination rate among adults
especially because i see that my
children are forced not to be taught at
school or only with a mask on
or under other conditions that simply
make things difficult
just because some adults don't want to
get vaccinated that's unbearable
despite the fact that vaccinations are
free and available in germany many
adults haven't been vaccinated yet the
philip family is hoping for their
solidarity so that children can enjoy
school freely again
and as we're waiting for more adults to
show solidarity and get vaccinated to
also protect those who cannot get a job
let's bring in professor dr york dutch
from university hospital cologne good to
have you with us and i know that you are
also president of the german society for
child and adolescent medicine
what's changed since the start of the
pandemic what kind of physical and also
psychological side effects can you
observe
well as we've heard in the
form of presentations
there are a number of psychological
issues on the one hand and
somatic issues on the other hand
for instance we have a lot more
eating disorders especially the
prevalence of
obesity has grown considerably
and likewise
depression and anxiety disorders are on
the rise
so that's really worrying us and
therefore we think it's
of utmost importance to keep the schools
open and
never close them again
of course
schools are set to be open at least in
the northern hemisphere now but we're
approaching autumn in winter here and
that usually means more viral infections
interesting enough
pediatricians already observe a
surprising surge of other viral
infections like the respiratory
syncytial virus which normally occurs
mostly in winter
what does that tell us about the kids
immunocompetence has has it been
weakened severely by those months of
isolation
well as a matter of fact the minor
competence hasn't changed at all it's
just that they haven't been exposed to
for instance the
rs virus
last winter and therefore they are not
immune against it
and now they are getting their immune
system gets confronted with those viral
agents for instance
and that causes a much larger population
of children to be infected and also be
admitted into the hospital awards
you even i mean there are kids with
respiratory infections in your words as
well and it's not kobe 19 how serious is
it
that's absolutely right at the very
moment it's a paradoxical situation if
you wish
we have about
well 20 to 30
patients
on the wards with
respiratory infections other than covet
and we haven't had any covet infections
at least in our hospital within the last
two to three weeks
and that even though in most industrial
countries
schools are open again but what does
that mean for kids aged 10 to 14 right
now they're in the highest coronavirus
incidence group will they all be
infected eventually
well
we we think as a matter of fact that
eventually everybody will be infected
within the next couple of years
however
the the situation for the children is
not as bad as for adults if they get
infected they have a milder cause as we
just pointed out on the other hand we
don't want to have them all infected at
the same time first of all some children
have a more severe cause and we want to
avoid everything that is causing illness
in children on the one hand and on the
other hand avoiding the pandemic to um
to be spread around and to spread to be
spread via children
is a
common goal for us all um so
we want to keep us we want to have as
few children infected as possible
while we keep the schools open
and just for those worried parents out
there
will their children's immune system
recover again right now as we said there
are more infections will all of this
been compensated once the pandemic is
over or other lasting effects
yes i definitely believe so i mean the
the children's immune system has to be
confronted with about
well 50 to 60 viral infections during
the um the first
10 years of age so
i mean this is now one and a half years
that haven't been
now characterized by lots of viral
infections and the children will just
have to um to cover up for that
in the next couple of years so at the
end of the day
there won't be a harm to the immune
system
as we can say at the very moment but
it's it's a
hard situation for the hospitals at the
moment right well professor dr york
dutch from university hospital in
cologne thank you so much for your time
and all the best
thank you very much to you
time for one of your questions now over
to derek
what lessons have we learned from covet
19 that could help us manage future
outbreaks with other viruses better
one thing pretty much all experts agree
on when it comes to the pandemic is that
it was going to come sooner or later
another
is that it almost certainly
won't be the last so
what is all the suffering brought us in
terms of prevention
and management strategies will we be
better prepared next time what have we
learned
well a lot actually i'm starting with
the idea that
a good offense is really the best
defense i think that at least in the
medium term we'll see a lot more
resources thrown
at the study and monitoring of emerging
diseases in general
information they provide
should help us improve global standards
for for what interventions should be
taken when
and and also hopefully lay the
groundwork
to make better decisions next time in
areas like
the distribution of medical equipment or
vaccines where
humanity has often stumbled really
pretty badly in the current pandemic
the pandemic has also taught us a huge
positive lesson about
the power of scientific collaboration
and and that i think
will continue to have an impact way way
beyond health care um in in thousands of
projects covet 19 brought researchers
from across a huge range of fields and
and industries together to solve a
planet-wide problem and and and many of
those
cross-disciplinary relationships
are not going to just fade away again
when when the pandemic ends
we now know a whole lot more than we did
one and a half years ago about things
like
which measures can really help contain
disease spread
or how to fast track clinical trials and
and and what has to happen to gain
public trust for the vaccines and the
medicines that the pharma industry
produces
we've gotten a lot wrong with coven 19
no question and we still are
but at least next time we'll know more
about what to watch out for and
hopefully
that'll help prevent us from making the
same mistakes again
and before we let you go if you're
european and fully vaccinated you can
now fly into the u.s again washington
scrapped the travel restrictions imposed
in spring 2020 that's all thanks for
watching